[Musique] rien ne l'a prédestiné à devenir député
mon invité a été femme de chambre dans un hôtel
pendant près de 20 ans elle a mené une grève
victorieuse de 22 mois contre son employeur et
depuis son élection elle s'efforce de porter la
voix des S voix à [Musique] l'Assemblée bonjour
Rachel kké bonjour alors vous êtes une combattante
c'est comme ça que vous vous définissez vous-même
une combattante dont la vie a basculé quand vous
aviez 12 ans en Côte d'Ivoire quand votre mère est
décédée ce drame dans votre vie il vous a conduit
à prendre des responsabilités familiales très
jeunes très tôt vous avez dû arrêter les études
à 12 ans pour travailler euh quand ma mère est
partie heureusement qu'elle m'a appris beaucoup
de choses donc à 12 ans je faisais manger à mes à
mes frères et à en même temps je partais à l'école
donc après en classe de CM2 j'avais plus la force
de faire les travaux mélangés à la maison et
puis aller en même temps à l'école faire les
deux choses ensemble donc un jour j'ai dit à mon
père que je préfère rester à la maison m'occuper
de mes frères que de continuer les études plus
tard vous êtes donc arrivé en France vous aviez
26 ans vous avez vécu notamment dans un squat avec
vos enfants à l'époque vous avez exercé plusieurs
métiers avant de devenir femme de chambre à
l'hôtel Ibis bâtignol à Paris c'était en 2003
vous y avez sur place enchaîné des cadences très
soutenues pendant des années jusqu'à 40 chambres
à nettoyer chaque jour pour 1300 € par mois
avec une tendinite au poignet que vous avez
eu des douleurs au dos et puis au mois de juillet
2019 vous êtes mise en grève avec une quarantaine
femme de femmes de chambre de cet hôtel on va
revoir ça en image cela fait maintenant près
d'une semaine qu'elles occupent le hall de l'hôtel
Ibis où elles travaillent elles sont femmes de
chambre gouvernantes toutes étrangères la liste de
leurs revendication est longue cadences infernales
obligation de laver soi-même sa tenue de travail
pas d'indemnité de repas et même un cas de viol
dénoncé devant la justice beaucoup d'entre
nous connait pas le droit de travail donc ils
exploitent au maximum ils nous exploitent au
maximum alors ces images qu'on vient de voir
c'était le tout début de votre combat je le disais
ça a duré 22 mois dans la pluie dans le vent dans
le froid qu'est-ce qui vous a fait tenir aussi
longtemps sans salaire mais ce qui nous a fait
tenir déjà c'est les conditions qu'on traversait
dans cet hôtel h et avec la sraitance on était mal
payé on avait des assements sexuels on avait des
assements moral on était tellement mal traité donc
ça franchement fallait qu'on soit de ça et c'est
un métier sachez que qui rend malade qui donne des
tendignit tu donn mal au dos des poigné qui qui
qui sfent des épaules qui se déboîent c'est un
boulot très très très pénite et très mal payé et
là nous ça nous a donné la force de pouvoir sortir
du silence pour mettre fin à ça alors à l'époque
vous étiez élu CGT hein au sein de de cet hôtel
vous êtes imposé un peu comme la la leader de de
cette grève le député LFI Erric coqurel qui est
venu vous soutenir plusieurs fois sur place dit de
vous elle a quelque chose qui magnétise elle est
forte elle a les mots justes elle n'a pas besoin
de lire et il vous qualifie de leader de masse
est-ce que vous saviez que vous aviez ce don là
de d'emmener les autres avec vous de transmettre
une énergie de porter leurs paroles avant cette
grève mais oui parce que au départ quand j'ai
j'ai commencé à faire le métier des femmes de
chambrees je voyais les justice qui se passait
et beaucoup de femmes de beaucoup de de ces femmes
ne savaient pas lire écrit et moi je me prenais
tout le problème dessus donc je les défendait donc
quand il y avait elles avaient un problème tout su
elles cherchait elle est où rachel est où Rachel
et malgré même que j'étais pas délégué syndicat
je partais devant le patron et je les défendais
pour leur dire c'était pas normal c'est dans votre
tempérament c'est dans mon tempérament j'aime
pas l'injustice voilà c'est comme ça là où il
y a l'injustice franchement je n'aime pas mais
je c'est dans le bon sens quoi je je j'essaie
de trouver des solutions pour ces femmesl donc ce
combat vous l'avez gagné le 25 mai 2021 euh votre
employeur a accepté d'augmenter les salaires de
payer des heures supplémentaires vous a accordé
aussi une prime pour les repas il a accepté
de baisser les cadences de ménage et alors un
an après avoir gagné ce combat vous avez accepté
d'en mener un autre quand la France insmis vous a
proposé d'être candidate au législativ est-ce que
vous avez hésité à vous lancer en politique quand
ils m'ont proposé d'être candidate au législative
j'ai dit ah c'est pas c'est un peu compliqué
comment est-ce que je connais pas la politique
mais bon et après le président de la France Insou
qui me dit non mais vous avez mené une lutte
victorieuse et que je sais que à l'Assemblée
nationale vous pourrez nous représenter et j'ai
pris confiance en moi parce que oui on a gagné
une on a gagné une grève très victorieuse pendant
22 mois mais pourquoi ne pas être la voix des S
voix à l'Assemblée nationale et là on voit votre
première prise de parole lors de du lancement
de la Nupe vous avez mis toute la salle debout
quelques semaines plus tard vous avez donc été
élu député face à une ancienne ministre he Roxana
maraciné à nous le soir de votre victoire vous
avez déclaré j'ai le niveau CM2 je dis merci aux
journalistes qui vont se mettre à mon niveau euh
on sent quand même une forte dose d'ironie dans
cette déclaration ça vous a agacé le regard que
les journalistes ont pu porter sur vous à l'époque
sur votre parcours il y a des journalistes qui
sont un peu méprisant mais bon je j'ai dis oui
je sais que ils vont prendre pour m'attaquer
je sais qu'ils vont m'attaquer mais je suis une
guerrière je les tiendra tête si un journaliste
me pose une question que je ne comprends
pas je ne réponds pas mais je n'ai pas peur
journaliste pour répondre euh les premiers pas
à l'Assemblée c'est toujours un peu compliqué
pour n'importe quel député qu'est-ce qui a
été le plus difficile pour vous euh déjà à
l'Assemblée nationale la télévision quand je
regardais souvent les autres députés avec la
cravate je me dis mais wouh avec des gens
qui sont formés qui ont bac plus 5 que ça
va être un peu voilà ça va être ça allait être
un peu difficile pour moi et comment est-ce que
j'allais y arriver pour comprendre les rouages
comment ça se passe à l'Assemblée nationale mais
enfin je j'ai compris que il faut se former et
ça m'a beaucoup formé j'ai j'ai compris beaucoup
de choses et je commence à comprendre encore
beaucoup de choses vous aviez promis d'être
la vois des S voix de ceux qui s'occupent de ce
que vous appelez les métiers essentiels et qui
sont pas ou peu représentés à à l'Assemblée
vous l'avez fait dès votre première prise de
parole dans l'hémicycle et puis vous l'avez fait
avec plus de force encore pendant la réforme des
retraites puisque vous étiez chef de fil des
députés LFI sur le sujet de la pébilité on va
revoir un extrait d'une de vos prises de parole
qui d'entre vous a déjà fait un métier pénible
qui d'entre vous peut lever la main et dire moi
aujourd'hui j'ai dû pousser des chariots avec
50 de kil de ciment j'ai dû m'occuper de 20
personnes âgées qui peut lever la main personne
vous n'avez pas le droit de mettre en genou les
gens qui tiennent la France debout c'est pourquoi
vous voterons contre cette réforme de retraite
nous serons je vous remercie ma chè [Musique]
collègu je vous remercie c'est fini on sent que
vous vivez à 200 % vos vos prises de parole vous
êtes vous êtes à fond oui je suis à fond parce que
c'est un sujet qui me tenait vraiment à cœur parce
que euh faire travailler quand même les gens 2
années de plus jusqu'en 64 ans sans penser euh
à des métiers pénibles c'est quand même dommage
parce que par exemple moi à l'époque quand j'étais
femme de chambre est-ce qu' a 64 ans est-ce que je
peux faire rien et alors mais il y a il y a quand
même aussi cette façon de pointer du doigt vos
collègues députés ou les ministres qui d'entre
vous a connu ça est-ce qu'il faut forcément avoir
connu les métiers pénibles pour pouvoir voter une
loi sur ce sujet-là mais j'ai dit oui parce que
quand tu sais quand tu connais quelque chose tu
fais beaucoup attention moi aujOurd'huii c'estd
vous vous abstenez sur les les sujets politiques
que vous ne connaissez pas personnellement dans
ce cas-là mais ça avant de je je m'abstiens si
je comprends pas je comprends que je sais que on
m'explique l'amendement ce que ça veut dire mais
je ne m' pas si ça va dans mon dans mon cadre ou
bien dans vers le cadre du peuple parce que moi
le problème comme j'ai dit je suis la voix des S
voix mais c'est pour représenter le bas peuple si
ça va dans dans l'intérêt du peuple mais je voilà
je je ne m'assin pas euh votre vie depuis votre
élection a radicalement changé ne serait-ce que
parce que votre salaire a a plus que triplé je
crois est-ce que vous avez peur au bout d'un
moment de vous déconnecter de ce que viv les
gens que vous voulez représenter mais je ne me
déconnect pas parce que je sais d'où je viens
quand tu sais d'où tu viens l'argent ne peux pas
faire que tu vas te déconnecter parce que tu as tu
as eu des amis tu tu comprends les gens il faut
vous vous êtes encore en relation avec vos Cies
cè de l'ôel ibisd oui oui oui je vais à l'hôtel
Ibis je vais les voir je vais parler avec eux je
leur explique comment ça se passe et leur regard
à vos anciennes collègu sur vous est-ce qu'il a
changé non ça n'a pas changé au contraire elles
sont très contentes euh d'être être là où je suis
elles sont vraiment heureuses parce que même un
jour j'ai été Mon' dit tu sais souvent quand les
clients viennent ici il nous disent ah mais c'est
ici est parti la la la femme de chambre qui a été
qui est à l'Assemblée nationale donc c'est une F
voilà c'est une fierté pour elle et voilà je vais
là-bas je leur donne les les conseils on parle
et même quand le directeur d'bis il me voit il
vient il me dit mais madame la députée vous pouvez
venir pour qu'on puisse discuter parce que je suis
de près eu leurs conditions de travail pour ne
pas que le pire arrive encore si ce qu'on a vécu
pendant les 22 mois vous êtes la première femme de
chambre à avoir été élue député ça fait de vous un
symbole il y a beaucoup de gens hein vous venez
de le dire qui se reconnaissent en vous qui ne se
sentit pas représenté avant à l'Assemblée et qui
aujourd'hui se sentent représenté vous pensez que
bientôt il y aura beaucoup d'autres Rachel kké à
l'Assemblée mais je veux bien je vous croez c'est
possible mais ça peut être possible ça dépend
des partis politiques mais comme l'a faire pour
moi la France insoumise je pense que d'autres
parties comme le les macronistes voilà le le RN
je pense queil faut qu'il propose certaines
personnes comme qui vientent du bas peup parce
que l'Assemblée nationale je pense que c'est on
est mieux représentés ceux qui font ces métiers
sont mieux représentés à l'Assemblée nationale
et pourront mieux défendre eux-mêmes le le leurs
conditions de travail en face du gouvernement
euh un dernier sujet juste après votre élection
il y a un site d'extrême droite F de souche qui
a révélé que vous avez relayé des messages de
soutien à Marine Le Pen en 2016 qu'est-ce que ces
messages disent de la Rachel kké de cette époque
est-ce que vous êes tu es sensible aux idées
de de Marine Le Pen à l'époque euh c'est pas
vraiment ça parce que vous savez quand tu vas au
travail tu tout le monde est tu as le portable à
l'époque je te connaissais pas la politique voilà
tu as ton portable tu partages tu regardes sans
comprendre exactement ce qu'il se passe voilà
donc c'est pas que moi j'ai jamais euh voté
Marie Le Pen je il y a pas une photo bien il y a
pas une image qui prouvve que j'étais à un r une
manifestation de mari de Pen non ça n'existe pas
en vant je comprenais pas la politique que faisait
Marie Le Pen mais depuis que j'ai été élu j'ai
j'ai compris beaucoup de choses surtout envers
euh les les immigrés comment il ils font leur
politiques envers les comment ils créent il
créent la division entre les Français il y a il
y a un autre sujet aussi euh qui a été révélé à
ce moment-là c'est qu'en 2018 vous avez relayé un
message de soutien à Bachar al-Assad un message
qui qualifiait la France de prédateur criminel
pour quelle raison c'était mais comme j'ai dis
je n'aime pas l'injustice parce que je voyais
aujourd'hui on défend le cause de la Palestine
voilà c'est c'était un peu pareil comme voilà
la politique de bacharass aujourd'hui je sais
pas parce que d'autres me ditent non mais il est
dictateur il est ceci mais à l'époque je savais
pas qu'il était dictateur moi je voyais seulement
que les bombardements et je trouvais que c'était
pas juste c'est tout mais je savais pas qu'il
était il était dictateur il était comme ça à
l'époque je le savais pas maintenant je sais on
va passer à notre quiz à présent euh donc je vous
explique le principe je vais commencer des phrases
et ça va être à vous de de les compléter vous
êtes prêt ok on y va quand une éditorialiste me
reproche de porter un boubou dans l'hémicycle mais
moi ça me fait rire ça vous a fait rire parce que
c'est ce qui s'est passé euh oui oui j'ai vu j'ai
vu mais ça me fait rire parce que je suis venu
j'étais pas en boubou je sais pas d'où sort l'idée
de Boubou donc ça m'a fait rire en fait d'accord
vous l'avez pris avec humour voilà mon principal
défaut c'est ah mon défaut moi mon défaut c'est
j'aime rigoler beaucoup parce que souvent me dit
mais toi tu prends tout à la légère bon je sais
pas si c'est un défaut mais bon voilà enfin si je
ne suis pas réélu en 2027 que FZ je ferai d'autres
choses il y a plein de choses dans le monde il
y a beaucoup de choses vous resterai quand même
engagé en politique oui je ser je resterai engagé
je vais pas baisser les bras surtout je ferai
euh comment je peux dire je je vais me mettre
dans une ONG pour défendre les femmes donner la
force aux femmes de ne pas baisser les bras de
continuer la lutte de voilà d'aller de
l'envant parce que dans la vie tout peut
tout peut tout peut être possible la combattante
jusqu'au bout voilà il faut qu'on batte jusqu'au
bout merci beaucoup Rachel keké d'avoir été
l'invité de la politique et moi [Musique]
merci